AS WE GO TO OUR NEXT GAME,
EXTREME PARENTING.
>> ALL RIGHT!
>> Chris: HEROES COME IN ALL
SHAMES, SIZES AND BLOOD ALCOHOL
LEVELS.
THIS WEEKEND, ONE HEROIC DAD NOT
ONLY SAVED HIS BJORNED BABY FROM
A FOUL BALL AT A BASEBALL GAME,
HE DID A LITTLE PEACOCKING TO
CELEBRATE HIS ACT OF VALOR. TAKE
A LOOK.
>> WATCH THIS, HERE WE GO.
>> OH, MY GOSH.
>> WHAT?
>> I MEAN, MY GOD.
>> Chris: YOU THOUGHT IT WAS
BAD TO BRING A BABY TO A
BASEBALL GAME AND WHERE HIM LIKE
A VEST, HUH?
YEAH, IF A BALL'S FLYING AT YOU
AND YOU HAVE A BABY ON YOUR
CHEST, DON'T [BLEEP]ING STAND
UP.
IT'S NOT A HUMAN SHIELD! IT'S
YOUR OFFSPRING.
COMEDIANS, I WANT YOU TO GIVE ME
AS MANY OTHER HEROIC ACTS OF BRO
DAD AS POSSIBLE IN 60-SECONDS
AND BEGIN.
ADAM PALLY.
>> FINDING OUT WHAT IS BETTER
FOR COLIC, AN INDIGA OR SATIVA.
>> Chris: POINTS.
BRETT GELMAN.
>> TEACHING ASTRONOMY BY DRAWING
THE SOLAR SYSTEM ON MY BACK WITH
A LIT CIGARETTE.
>> Chris: POINTS.
KATHRYN.
>> TEACHING YOUR SON ABOUT THE
QUIET AND SIMPLE POETRY OF
LIGHTING YOUR OWN FARTS.
>> Chris: YES.
POINTS.
BRETT.
>> SELLING "ALL LIVES MATTER"
T-SHIRTS AT THE NURSERY BAKE
SALE.
>> Chris: YES.
POINTS.
KATHRYN.
>> FATHER-SON TRIPS TO THE
SPEARMINT RHINO.
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT, POINTS.
BRETT GELMAN.
>> SLUT-SHAMING MY
THREE-YEAR-OLD SISTER.
HE'S A BRO DAD, HE'S A PIECE OF
(BLEEP).
YOU GET THE JOKE? COME
ON.
>> Chris: YEAH, FROM THAT
CHARACTER'S POINT OF VIEW --
THAT'S NOT WHAT BRETT SAID.
ALTHOUGH THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
BRETT WOULD SAY.
HE IS IN CHARACTER RIGHT NOW.
ADAM.
>> I JUST HAVE TO GET AWAY FROM
IT.